[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه ستون
برنامج اخباري خاص ومتنوع وبقاع سريع
ومختلف جدا نحلل الاحداث بابعادها وبعمق
وبين العاجل والمهم نضع امامكم الاهم
والصوره الكامله البدايه من العناوين عام
جديد على حرب غيرت العالم الصين كلمه السر
اما لانهائها او لاشعالها
القنبله النوويه خط اسرائيل الاحمر يقترب
ايران من تجوزه والرد الهجوم يقترب وفي
ملفات الساعه ستون الفقر يقض مضاجع
الايرانيين مشاهد مشهد تؤكد المؤكد واقع
صعب وميزانيه بلا عداله
ابو زلازل في تركيا زلزال جديد وهزات
بالالاف توسع دائره الخطر
[موسيقى]
احلموا ان انجب طفلا يسالني امي ما معنى
الحرب كلمات الكاتبه والشاعر الشهيره
الامريكيه افلين ميريام لا يبدو انها
ستكون واقعا في المستقبل القريب فحرب
روسيا واوكرانيا التي دخلت عامها الثاني
جعلت كل الناس بمختلف اعمارهم يعرفون معنى
الحرب حتى وان لم تكن رحاها تدور على ارض
بلادهم
كله تاخر الحرب غيرت العالم لكن بقي ثابت
وحيد مشاهد الدمار والقتل اكثر من 21 الف
مدنيا قتلوا وهذا رسميا بينما التقديرات
تشير لنحو 100 الف القتلى والجرحى من جنود
الطرفين يقدرون بنحو 300 الف هذا هو معنى
الحرب لكن هل العام الثاني قد يسعى فيه
الجانبان لما هو اهم من الطلقات الكلمات
السعي الى السلام يحدث عندما يتم استفاده
جميع اشكال العدوان امر لا يلوح في الافق
الان تركيا التي كانت الوسيطه الابرز خلال
العام الماضي قد تتاثر وسطتها بسبب كارثه
الزلزال التي ضربتها والانتخابات المقبله
عليها وهنا
ظهر لاعب اخر الصين بخطتها المؤلفه من 12
عشره نقطه رحبت بها روسيا طبعا بينما شككت
بها اوكرانيا وحلفائها وبناء على تاريخ
تعاون موسكو وبكيني ومع رف الاخيره وصف ما
قامت به روسيا بالغزو لكن تبقى املا ولو
كان بسيطا المانيا وفرنسا طلبتها الرئيس
الاوكراني زلينسكي بالتفكير جديا في
مفاوضات السلام وهو الذي اعلن انه لا يريد
لقاء بوتين مساعدات الغرب لك اياه يبدو
انها جعلت زيلينسكي يطمع في المزيد من
الانتصارات على روسيا اعلن استعداد
السيطره العسكريه على القرم بينما حذره
المسؤولون الالمان والفرنسيون لن تكونوا
قادرين على ذلك اذا ماده الصين يدها من
اجل السلام تسعى لانهاء الحرب وهي التي قد
تاخذ حربا مشابهه في تايوان وتتوجه
مقاتلاتها بشكل خطر ومتزايد مع مقاتلات
امريكيه مثلما حدث يوم امس فوق بحر الصين
الجنوبي لكن باليد الاخرى قد تشعل الصراع
اكثر تعتزم بكين بدا انتاج مسيرات هجوميه
للجيش الروسي تمهيدا للاستخدام في
اوكرانيا شركه تصنيع المسيرات الصينيه
تكنولوجي جاهزه لانتاج 100 طائره بدون
طيار من نوع زدتي 180 وهدمت تؤكده المصادر
الاستخباراتيه في الولايات المتحده واكدته
مصادر المانيه ايضا وفقا لصحيفه
المسيرات الصينيه تشبه مسيرات شاهد 136
الايرانيه والتي تستخدمها روسيا والتي
اعلنت بريطانيا اليوم ان مخزونها ينفذ لدى
موسكو شركه صينيه اخرى يسيطر عليها الجيش
خططت لامر اخر وهواء وامداد روسيا بقطع
غيار لطائراتها المقاتله وتحديدا
والغطاء تصدر معدات للاستخدام المدني
انصحت هذه التقارير ودخلت الصين كلاعب
جديد قد يتعقد الصراع بالطبع مع استمرار
الدعم العسكري الغربي الكبير لاوكرانيا
المزيد الاسلحه يعني سعاده اقل والمزيد من
المناطق يعني المزيد من البؤس كلمه الزعيم
الهندي جاندي طبعا الصين النفت كل هذه
التقارير بينما الولايات المتحده وبشكل
رسمي لديها رايان واحد من يؤكد واخر من
بايدن ينفي
في الذكرى الاولى للحرب
لم تبدا بعد اهداف الرئيس الروسي هي نفسها
اوكرانيا بشكلها الحالي لا تستحق الوجود
النازيه لم تعد ذنبها الوحيد واراضيها
اصبحت ميدان حرب الوكاله يحركها الغرب
اكبر الداعمينسكي بايدن لم يترك رمزيات
الذكرى رهينه لكلمه بوتين تجول في شوارع
كييف تحت صافره انذار وهميه
رساله حملت دعما معنويا يتعدى تاثير
السلاح اداره اراده الاوكرانيين وحدها
اوقفت بوتا عند تخوم كييفا قبل عام
مواصله الحرب
[موسيقى]
اذا هي واشنطن مواصله الحرب حتى اخر
اوكرانيا هكذا ترى موسكو الامر بينما تضخ
امريكا المال والسلاح وتدفع اوكرانيا
ضريبه بقائها بالدماء فرصه لم تحلم به
مواطن من قبل اضعاف روسيا واحياء النيتو
هنا يجب العوده الى الواقعيه خلصت روسيا
اهدافها تدريجيا طوال عام الى تقدم بات
يحسب بالامطار لا شيء مقارنه بما يقترب
النيتو من تحقيقه
1350 كيلو مترا من فنلندا تضاف الى حدوده
مع روسيا لكن مع المراوحه العسكريه
الروسيه جاءت مفاجاه اقتصاديه الانكماش
بعد عام من الحرب لم يتعدى 2.1% معجزه في
زمن الحرب والعقوبات غير المسبوقه اكثر من
14000 توجت موسكو بلقب الدوله الاكثر
تعرضا للعقوبات في العالم والروبل صمد
باعتراف واشنطن
مفعول العقوبات عكسي رغم ان اوروبا تجاوزت
الشتاء باقل الخسائر هذا في التصريحات
الرسميه اما في الواقع فالتضخم افاق قدره
الاوروبيين لينعكس ذلك على تعهدات بلدانهم
لكياب حصلت على اربعين في المئه فقط من
المساعدات المعلنه
مساعدات اضافيه لا تقل عن 33 مليار يورو
بحسب عده تقارير التقارير ذاتها تشير الى
انك يفقد حصلت على اقل من نصف الاموال
التي وعدت بها العمل الماضي حيث حصلت
وزاره الماليه الاوكرانيه على 31 مليار
يورو من مجموع 64 مليار كانت قد وعدت بها
ما يؤخر وصول المساعدات الغربيه لاوكرانيا
سريعا هو الاجراءات المعقده لدى الغرب
فالاتحاد الاوروبي يحتاج احيانا لما يزيد
عن سته اشهر كامله للحصول على بعض
الموافقات القانونيه والسياسيه لبعض
المساعده الماليه القياده السياسيه
الاوكرانيه من جهتها تقول ان هذا التاخير
يمثل مشكله كبيره لا سيما عندما تكون في
خضم حرب وان على الغرب الا ينسى انك لا
تدافع عن نفسها فقط وانما تدافع عن كامل
الاراضي الاوروبيه
بين هجوم روسيا وهجوم مضاد اوكرانيين حرب
موازيه لم تهدا عالميه كفتها رجحت منذ
البدايه لاوكرانيا الكريم اليوم يعاني من
فردي روايه حتى داخل روسيا نفسها اعتقاد
لاستمرار
الصوتيه دون صوره وانتقاد لتقارير الحرب
التي يتلوها ايغورب
وصفت بانها صوره مفصوله عن الواقع روسيا
حضرت كل القنوات الغربيه لديها واقرت
قوانين رائعه لكل لكل من ينتقد العمليات
العسكريه والمعارضه وصفه الخطوه بفرض
اساليب القرن العشرين على اعلام العصر
الجديد في المقابل اصطفت وسائل الاعلام
الغربيه وراء اوكرانيا واغلقت ابوابها
امام دعيم موسكو اما في اوكرانيا تحولت
الدعايه الى مشروع قومي التقطه الشعب
حسابه وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه على تويتر
خير ومثال يديره خمسه خبراء هدفهم الاول
ضمان تناسق كل المقاطع الخاصه
مع ابعاد المكان والزمان هذا الفيديو مثلا
موجه لبريطانيا الحان الموسيقار
الانجليزيه هوسكو ستوب وفريق ذا كلاش مع
اقتباس
الاصدقاء يبكون اصدقاء لكن مخاطبه
الاليزات تختلف جذريا عرضا لمعالم باريس
ترافقه موسيقى
وفي النهايه يقدم الطلب على طبق من
الرومانسيه طلب مدافع سيزار معركه اخرى في
الرياضه في الوقت الذي تطالب فيه زخرف
يوميا عن حق بلادها في المشاركه في
اولمبيادت تعمل ثياب على فرض رايها بطريقه
مختلفه
[موسيقى]
جره اوكرانيا الى حرب استنزاف امر لن
يستطيع الغرب مواكبته التي تحدث عنها
بايدن لكن قمه رمشتاين بدايه العام اجبرت
روسيا على تعديل الخطه بل ورسمت جزءها
المفقود تسليح كييف لا يسمح باختراق
دفاعات الروسيه في العمق دبابات كياب دمرت
ووصول الامدادات الغربيه منها يحتاج
لاسابيع الا ان اوكرانيا تصر على ان
الهجوم الروسي الشامل بدا منذ اسبوعين
بتعزيز القوات وليس بفتح جبهات جديده
ودللت على ذلك بان الهجمات الروسيه تضاعفت
واعداد الجنود ايضا
330 الفن مقابل
220 الف عنصر رو بدايه العام هذا وموسكو
لم توظف بعد 200 الف جندي ممن تم تعبئتهم
جزئيا ما هي الخطه اذا فتح جبهه جديده من
بيلاروسيا بات مستبعدا الاوكرانيون
يناورون في دائره اصغر جغرافيا عكس الروس
وصول القوات الى بيلاروسيا شمالا او الى
اوديسا جنوبا يحتاج وقتا وهو ما لن يترك
مجالا للمفاجاه وعلى اثر ذلك قررت موسكو
تعديل الخطه هي الان تهدف لي منع اوكرانيا
من تشكيل احتياطات لبناء هجوم مضاد وقبل
ان يفتح جنود الاحتياط الروس جبهه جديده
باتجاه
خطيبولوجيا قبل توافد المساعدات الغربيه
على الوحدات الاوكرانيه هل تنازلت موسكو
اذا عن العوده لقياد ربما خاصه وانها
ستكون اكثر كلفه من المره الاولى اوكرانيا
بنت العديد من التحصينات على طول الحدود
تعداد واعتاد الجيش الروسي
لا يسمح بالهجوم
[موسيقى]
بمرور الوقت اتضح ان الجبهه الروسيه في
اوكرانيا عباره عن اتحاد مجموعه من الجيوش
تتقاسم الميدان على النصر من انتقاد
الجنرالات الى قائد الاركان مباشره
بريكوجين
اتهموب بمحاوله القضاء على فيغنر رغم انها
تحارب في الصفوف الاماميه في معركه بخموت
الوحشيه
نشرت صورا لخسائرها البشريه خلال يوم واحد
والسبب لا يعود لاسلوب الدفع بالامواج
البشريه الذي تتبناه الى ازمه ذخيره ناجمه
عن خيانه جرازيمون
نشر وثائق تثبت ان فاجنر لم تستلم الا 50%
من شحنات الذخيره داعيا الروس بالضغط على
وزاره الدفاع انقاضا ارواح المقاتلين
النداء واثمر الامدادات في الطريق
اختار الموعد بعنائها في ذكرى الحرب
الاولى الكرملين بحاجه لنصر معنوي لكنه
ذكر وزاره الدفاع بعجزها عن تحقيق الاهداف
وهو ما ترك المجال لبلاد
عسكريا الخاصه في اوكرانيا عام حافل شهدت
من خلاله موسكو اولا عمليه تعبئه جزئيه
للقوات قامت من خلالها بتجديد اكثر من 300
الف جنديا روسي بالاضافه الى المتطوعين
كما شهدت تغييرا متكررا للقاده العسكريين
للعمليه العسكريه ثالثا زياده التعداد
القوات المسلحه الروسيه الذي سيرتفع الى
مليون ونصف المليون فرد في الفتره من 2023
الى 2026 واخيرا الاتهامات التي وجهها
قائد مجموعه الخاصه الى وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه
بتعمد حرمان قواته من الذخيره الكافيه
والتي بدورها نفد صحتها لكن على الرغم من
كل ذلك ووفقا لمركز ابحاث الراي العام
لعموم روسيا زاد مستوى ثقه الروس بالرئيس
بوتين الى
والذي برره الكرملين بان اللحظه الحاسمه
التي تمر بها موسكو دفعت المجتمع الى
التضامن حول الرئيس
الداخل الاسرائيلي المنتجر قد يقيد مواجهه
ايران في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
ليس مشهدا من فيلم السينمائي استخدم منتجه
كل عناصر الخدع البصريه لاظهاره بهذه
الجوده اللقطه حقيقيه شاب فلسطيني يرفع
العلم عاليا خلال تظاهرات في عده مدن
فلسطينيه انتفضت واعلنت اضطرابا شاملا
والسبب كما جرت العاده الانتهاكات
الاسرائيليه الاربعاء الماضي شنت القوات
الاسرائيليه هجوما على نابلس شمالي الضفه
الغربيه قتلت خلالها 11 فلسطينيا واصابت
اكثر من مئه اخرين
الحرب في اوكرانيا تفاقم خطرا نووي
الايراني قرار موسكو تعليق روسيا معاهده
نيو ستارت اقلقت تل ابيب من غياب مراقبه
موسكو لفائض اليورانيوم الايراني والقرار
جاء في وقت تقترب طيران من تجاوز الخط
الاحمر بصنع قنبله النوويه يفصلها عن ذلك
فقط 6% بحسب الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه وهذا لتخصيب اليورانيوم سرا لنسبه
كشف ماثان مشبوه ظهر قبل ذلك تعديل سري في
منشاه بوردو بربط مجموعتين من اجهزه الطرد
المركزي من طراز اي ار 6 لتخصيب
اليورانيوم بعيدا عن اعين المفتشين وكاله
ايران تنفي باسرار رفع درجه التخصيب وتعزو
التقرير مفتشين وكاله بانه اما خاطئ او
مسيس رغم انها اقرت بوجود جزيئات تزيد
نسبه التقسيط فوق الستين في المئه لكن حسب
ما قالوها هذا لا يعني الانتاج بتخصيب
اعلى من هذه النسبه مراقبه هذا التطور
النووي في توجس وفي مقدمتهم اسرائيل
مستشارها للامن القومي خرج لينتقد تعاطي
الوكاله مشيرا الى ان هذه النسبه تثبت ان
البرنامج النووي ليس للاستخدام المدني
وبينما تجري الوكاله ومديرها رفيال روسي
محادثات مع ايران حول نتائج انشطه التفتيش
الاخيره تدعم واشنطن تل ابيب ضد تهديداتي
ايران
باكملها
[موسيقى]
كل الخيارات متاحه اذا ليكون السؤال ما هي
الخيارات التي تمتلكها اسرائيل ان وصلت
ايران لنسبه التخصيب اللازمه لانتاج قنبله
نوويه الخيار الابرز والمطروح منذ فتره هو
تنفيذ هجوم على المنشات النوويه الايرانيه
وخلال الاسبوع الماضي فقط بحسب الاعلام
الاسرائيلي اجرى رئيس الحكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو خمسه نقاشات سريه بحثت هذه الخطه
ورفع جهوديه جهوزيه الجيش لتنفيذها
نتنياهو يرى ان التهديد النووي الايراني
لن يتراجع الا بعمل عسكري العقوبات
الاقتصاديه ليست كافيه
اذا هناك خطه للهجوم لكن هل تل ابيب جاهزه
للتنفيذ مصادر عسكريه اسرائيليه قبل شهر
واحد من الان اكدت ان خطه الهجوم على
منشات ايران النوويه ليست جاهزه تماما وان
التحضير لانك هذا سيستغرق عامين على الاقل
لكن بالفعل تحضر اسرائيل نفسها لهجوم كهذا
منذ فتره ففي سبتمبر عام 2021 جزء كبير من
زياده الميزانيه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
من اجل شم هجوم على ايراني قبل ايام
استثنت تل ابيب ميزانيه الدفاع من مناقشات
الموازنه زادت مخصصات برنامج ضرب ايران
بنحو مليارين و800 مليون دولار في مايو من
العام الماضي اجرى سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي
مناورات واسعه النطاق والهدف كان واضحا
محاكاه هجوم على المواقع النوويه
الايرانيه ميزانيه وخطه وتدريبات لكن ثمه
امرا قد يعرقل خططنا
داخل الاسرائيلي المتفجر
بعيدا عن كلام السياسيين الاسرائيليين
لاهداف داخليه فان دوائر امنيه
واستراتيجيه اسرائيليه تحذر من تابعات
مابات يوصف بالانقلاب على نظام القضاء في
اسرائيل لجهه التاثير على ملف الامن
تحديدا اولا من خلال ان ذلك قد يفهم ضعفا
من قبل قوى خارجيه مثل حزب الله والفصائل
الفلسطينيه ما قد يغريها للعمل العسكري
وثانيا ضرب معنويات قوات الاحتياط التي
تشكل ثلاثه ارباع الجيش الاسرائيلي في
القتال في الحرب المقبله وثالثا والاهم
التاثير على المواجهه مع ايران لجهه تضرر
العلاقه مع واشنطن فمثلا مجلس الامن لم
يناقش تخصيب ايران لليورانيوم لاكثر من
ثمانين في المئه لكنه اذان سياسه
الاستيطان الاسرائيليه
[موسيقى]
ولانه لا جهه تبنت الهجوم فما زال الغموض
يكتنف تفاصيلها روايته المصادر في
المعارضه السوريه اضافت شقا اخر للقصه
قائد فيلق القدس اسماعيل القائني كان
الهدف وهو الذي كان متواجدا في سوريا
لمتابعه مساعدات الزلزال التي ارسلتها
طهران لدمشق ثم حضر اجتماعا لحركه الجهاد
الفلسطينيه
غير موقعه بناء على نصيحه روسيه الامر
نفسه اكدته الاذاعه الاسرائيليه شخصيه
كبيره كانت مستهدفه لم لكن هذه الروايه
نفاها مصدر بفيلق القدس في تصريحات لشبكه
روسيا اليوم وبمناسبه الحديث عن زياره
قائان لسوريا مسؤولون عسكريون اسرائيليون
حذروا من استغلال طهران للمساعدات الدوليه
الخاصه بالزلزال بهدف ارسال اسلحه ومعدات
الى ميليشياتها في المنطقه لكن يبدو ان تل
ابيب متيقظه لهذا الامر تحاول بين الحين
والاخر استهداف هذه الشحنات رغم عالم
الاعلان طبعا اخرها ثم نهايه يناير الماضي
استهداف قافله شاحنات في المنطقه الواقعه
تحت سيطره ايران الشرقي سوريا على ماذا
احتوت القافله اسلحه مهربه بحسب معلوماتي
ايران انترناشونال خصوصا وان القافله تتبع
الوحده 190 في فيلق القدس ذراع الحرس
الثوري لتهريب الاسلحه للمناطق المتضرره
من الازمه في المنطقه
[موسيقى]
ومن تل ابيب ينضم الينا المحلل العسكري
الاسرائيلي يا العليمه عبر سكايب اهلا بك
اذا هناك الان ضوء اخضر من امريكا لتحركا
اسرائيلي ضد ايران هو واضح وايضا هناك عدم
جهوزيه في اسرائيل لكن مع هذا الخطر
المتعاظم في ايران بتخصيب يتجاوز الاربعه
وثمانين في المئه او يصل الى هذه النسبه
ما هي اولويات تل ابيب وكيف ستتحرك امام
هذا الخطر
اولا لا اعتقد ان هناك ضوء اخضر من واشنطن
للقيام بضربه عسكريه ربما ما نستمع اليه
خلال الايام الاخيره من الجهات
الاسرائيليه ان هناك قلق كبيره
حول
ان هذا هو
الاتجاه اسرائيل
انها كما
تشير الى ان الخيار هو الخيار الوحيد في
هذه الظروف ولكن يبدو ان واشنطن لم تستجيب
للتطلعات الاساليه بمعنى ان اسرائيل لا
تزال تنتظر
تو
اجه وتطلع الخيار العسكري امام التهديد
الايراني هذا لم ياتي من ناحيه صحيح
اسرائيل او الجيش الاسرائيلي غير مستعد
للقيامه بمثل هذه العمليه الانباء التي
[موسيقى]
روج الى سلسله اللقاءات التي عقدت ان رئيس
الوزراء او عزابي
هذا لا يعني
المنشات في الايرانيه اسرائيل لا استطيع
بعد
فيها تنفيذ هذه العمليه علينا
استعداد والى الجاهزيه من نوع اخر صحيح
خلال اشهر الماضيه
الخطوات في مراحيلها في مراحل الاعداد لها
في هذه المرحله
ستتطلب كم من الوقت
تتحدث عن عامين هذه هي التقديرات هل هي
منطقيه وواقعيه
هذا صحيح الاعتقاد انه على الاقل تحتاج
الى سنه كامله
لاتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه لتحضير القوات
وكما ذكرت هذا ليس فقط لا يعني فقط اعداد
الخطط او تجهيز للطائرات وانما هذا يعني
الاستعداد لمعركه شامله متعدده الجبهات
ايضا هذا ايضا سيد اياد على الجانب
العسكري والجهوزيه هناك ايضا الانقسام
الداخلي حول القرار بشان الملفات الامنيه
وهذا الذي تابعناه في الفتره الماضيه صحيح
صحيفتها ارتس نقلت عن مسؤولين ايرانيين
اسرائيليين كانوا ضد الانسحاب الامريكي من
اتفاق النووي والان هم يؤكدون على ضروره
مواجهه الخطر الايراني الناجم عن
التخصيب النووي المتزايد ولكن الى اي مدى
ستعكس او تعاكس الانق بالداخل الخطوات
التي يمكن ان ياخذها نتنياهو
[موسيقى]
في مثل هذه الحاله عندما نرى
الاسبوعيه التي في المدن
مثل هذه الحاله اسرائيل
الى عمليه عسكريه ويبدو ان قياده الجيش
والمستوى السياسي
الوضع مع ذلك ما نستمع اليه كل هذه
الاجباه وكل هذه التصريحات يبدو لي انها
موجهه بدرجه الاولى الى واشنطن وربما هذه
النقطه هامه العلاقات بين اسرائيل واشنطن
ايضا في حاله من التوتر على خلفيه
الانقلاب بالقضاء والقلق في الولايات
المتحده او في الاداره الامريكيه من
التغيير الطابع النظام الاسرائيلي يبدو
انه في هذه المرحله
تستطيع ان توجه
ولكن
التوجه الى عمليه عسكريه وارده في هذه
الظروف
وخاصه العسكريه والداخليه
من تل ابيب كنت معنا المحلل العسكري
الاسرائيلي يا العليمه شكرا
[موسيقى]
تطوير ايران لبرنامجها نووي يجعل من
العوده لاتفاق عام 2015 مستعصيا المفاوضات
المتوقفه اصلا والنتيجه ضغط اقتصادي اكبر
على طهران المكبله بالعقوبات والعائد
مواطنها للتظاهرات قبل اسابيع احتفل
النظام الايراني بالذكرى الرابعه
والاربعين للثوره وقتها في
1979 كان حوالي عشرين في المئه من
الايرانيين يعيشون تحت خط الفقر الوعود
كانت براقه حينها لكن ماذا عن النتيجه
الفعليه عام 2021 وصلت نسبه من يعيشون تحت
خط الفقره الى 52% وفي العام الماضي فقط
بات ثلث سكان البلاد البالغ عددهم 90
مليون نسمه يعيشون في فقر متقع الاقتصاد
يعاني وصل الدولار الى 49 الف تومان هذه
الارقام انعكست طبعا على المواطنين ارتفعت
الاسعار بشكل جنوني الايرانيون بعثوا غير
قادرين على تلبيه الاحتياجات الاساسيه فما
السبب في كل هذا هل هو قرارات الحكومه
الخاطئه وما الذي اتخذه المسؤولون من
قرارات لمعالجه الامر هذه الاسئله طرحت
على وزير الاقتصاد فكيف كان بده
جزيل الشكر لدي طلب وهو ان ارد على الجزء
الاول من السؤال في المؤتمر المقبل فارجو
ان تتفضلي بتكرار السؤال حتى اجلب معي
الارقام لتساعد على تصحيح التحليلات في
الفضاء الافتراضي والاجتماعي في البلد
لانني لم اكن مستعدا للرد على هذا السؤال
لا يملك المسؤول الرد فمن اذا لديه
الاجابه ربما نعرف من خطاب سري للغايه
ارسله الامين العام لمجلس الامن القومي
الايراني علي شمخاني للرئيس ابراهيم رئيس
في الخامس من فبراير اعترف شامخاني لرئيسي
ان طهران تواجه ازمه كبيره في السلع
الاساسيه قطاع الخاص الايرانيين لم يبرم
عقودا مع بائعين اجانب للاشهر المقبله
رساله اخرى اختلف مرسلها لكن محتواها لم
يتغير في ديسمبر الماضي رئيس استخبارات
الحرس الثوري محمد كاظمي لرسالته الى محمد
مخبر النائب الاول لرئيسي حذره من التهديد
الخطر الذي يواجهه الامن الغذائي للمجتمع
الايراني
هذه الرسائل تاتي متزامنه مع شحن كبير في
عدد من السلع الاساسيه وزياده اسعار البعض
الاخر بشكل كبير ولناخذ بعض الامثله الذره
مثلا اثرت سياسه النظام في الحرب
الاوكرانيه على توفرها في السوق الايرانيه
كيف ترفض بيع الذره لطيران بسبب دعم
الاخيره العسكري لروسيا بالطائرات المسيره
منتجات اخرى ارتفعت اسعارها وبشكل جنوني
ومنها اللحوم سعر الكيلو تجاوز 500 الف
تومان والنتيجه بعض المواطنين قرروا عدم
الشراء بينما البعض الاخر اتجه الى
التقسيط عدد من الصحف تناولت قصه غلاء
الاسعار وتحديدا اللحوم والدواجن مثل
صحيفه تعادل الاقتصاديه وصحيفه سانداتكي
الاصلاحيه
لتنهالتهم لتشويش الراي العام ونقل محتوى
مغاير للواقع لجنه الرقابه على وسائل
الاعلام اوقفت صحيفه سازانتكي لتقصي
الحقيقه سنذهب لعدد من المدن ومنها مشهد
حاضنه النظام ومسقط راس خ
س
لوها
معاناه كبيره للايرانيين جعلت من شراء
القوت اليومي امرا شاقا وامام ذلك لا يصرف
النظام موارده على تخفيف من المعاناه بل
على زياده وتطوير وسائل القمع في يناير
الماضي وافق المشرعون الايرانيون على
الخطوط العريضه لمشروع قانون الميزانيه
للسنه التي تبدا في الحادي والعشرين من
مارس المقبل الانفاق كان للجهات التي كانت
ناشطه في التعامل مع التظاهرات زيادات
كبيره مقارنه بالعام الماضي وزاره
الاستخبارات ازدادت ثلاثه واربعين في
المئه الشرطه اكثر من 44% لجنه الامر
بالمعروف والنهي عن المنكر 33% الحرس
الثوري هو الاخر زاد طبعا لنسبه 37% كل
هذا معلن لكن السري اظهرته وثيقه نشرتها
ايران انترناشونال الحارس الثوري طالب
الحكومه بعدم اعلان ميزانيه شرطه الاخلاق
من اجل منع نشرها سيضحض فكره اعلان حلها
كل هذا يصرف بينما تضمنت الميزانيه زياده
رواتب موظفي الحكومه بنسبه 20% زياده نعم
لكن ظاهريه فقط هي في الواقع تخفيض
الاسعار زادت اكثر من الرواتب ليس بالتضخم
ارتفعت لمستويات قياسيه وصلت الشهر الجاري
الى اكثر من
53% وبالتالي القوه الشرائيه انخفضت لكن
في هذه الاثناء هناك من يرى ذلك عدلا راس
الدوله
الذي يتحدث عنه الرئيس الايراني لا تعكسه
ارقام الميزانيه ستجعل الناس اكثر فقرا
بحسب خبير في منظمه الخطه والميزانيه
الايرانيه وبالتالي انفجر الايرانيون في
الشوارع مره اخرى بعد فتره من الهدنه
[موسيقى]
اسطنبول في خطر فهل هي مستعده الساعه بعد
دقيقه
اهلا بكم من جديد يبدو ان المشاهد المرعبه
باتت مالوفه في محافظه هاتاي واحده من
اكثر الاماكن تضررا من زلزال الساده من
فبراير بعدها باسبوعين العشرين من فبراير
كانت فرق لانقاذ المحليه والدوليه على وشك
هائتها في الولايه عندما اعلنت اداره
الكوارث التركيه اعاده التوجيه الفرق
للمدينه مره اخرى السبب هو زلزال جديد
بقوه 6.4 درجات على مقياس ريختر بالصدفه
وفي هاتاي في نفس الوقت كان وزيره الدفاع
والصحه ورئيس الاركان التركيه يعقدون
اجتماعا في مركز اداره الكوارث حدث
الزلزال خرجوا من المبنى وانتظروا في احدى
الحدائق وبين هذين الزلزالين كانت هناك
اكثر من 9000
اخرها اليوم يعني ان الزلزال الاول يتبع
لقانون اموري ومعناه ان معدل الهزات
الارتداديه قد تستمر لشهور وسنوات رغم
انها تتناقص مع مرور الزمن لكن ورغم ان
الزلزال الاخير كان اقل بخمسه وعشرين ضعفا
من الزلزال الاول لكنه كان قويا هناك
ضحايا 42 مصابا في شمال غربيه سوريا
وانهار عدد من المباني ورغم انه قوي شعر
به سكان مصر وفلسطين ولبنان لكن حصيلته
كانت ضئيله عوامل عده حدت من اثاره
[موسيقى]
الاتراك باتوا يعانون من رهاب الزلازل هل
يمكن ان تحدث موجه اكبر في مدن منكوبه
ومدن اخرى
الزلزال الاول جاء نتيجه الانتقال بين
الصدع البحر الميت وصدع شرق الاناضول الذي
يبدا بمدينه هاتاي بمدينه موش امر ادى الى
تمزيق جزء كبير من ثلث الجنوبي الغربي من
صدع شرق الاناضول وكذلك الجزء الشمالي من
الصدع البحر الميت الخوف هنا ان يزيد
الضغط على غرب او يسار منطقه الزلزال
ايمكن ان تحدث زلازل الاخرى او حتى
تسونامي في قبرص اضنه وبالقرب من بحر ايجه
هناك خطر اخر موجود منذ 2018 فرصه بنسبه
95% ان يضرب الزلزال اسطنبول زلزال بقوه
سبع درجات او اقوى والسبب توسع الفجوه
الزلزاليه مع التشققات التي احدثها زلزله
1912 و 1999 بمنطقه صدع شمال الاناضول وهي
واحده من اكثر مناطق الصدعه نشاطا وربما
فتكا في العالم هذه التشققات زادت بالقرب
من بحر مرمره الذي سيكون مصدر الزلزال
اسطنبول انحدث وفي بحر اخر الابيض المتوسط
التخوف من تسونامي قريب خاصه مع الزلازل
الزلزال الجديد الذي ضرب هاتاي الساحليه
وانتشار صور تظهر تراجع منسوب مياه البحر
علميا يبدو السيناريو مستبعدا العلماء
اكدوا ان تراجع المياه يعود لعامل المد
والجزر المتوقع ان يحدث مره ثانيه في
الشهر والنقطه الثانيه يجب ان يكون
الزلزال قويا سبع بسبع درجات على الاقل
واكثر
ثماني درجات للحصول على تسونامي خطر
الزلزال الاول كان قريبا من ثماني درجات
لكن ما جعلت تسونامي امرا غير وارد هو
بعده عن البحر الاخير وان كان اقرب للبحر
كونها تاي مدينه ساحليه كانت قوته قلت عن
سبع درجات
وليقعد تسونامي ايضا يجب ان يتسبب الزلزال
في حركه راسيه لقاع البحر تصل الى عده
امتار بينما تكون حركه صداقه شرق الاناضول
غالبا افقيه وليست راسيه
الخطر الذي تحدثنا عنه فيما يخص الزلزاله
قويا قد يحدث في اسطنبول يمكن الاستعداد
له بغض النظر عن توقيته وفي المكسيك دليل
عام 1985 زلزال بقوه 8 درجات ثمانيه فاصله
واحد درجه اكثر من عشره الاف قتيل في
مكسيكو سيتي ومحيطها تجربه مريره قررت
البلاد بعدها الاستعداد والوسيله نظام
انذار مبكر سكان العاصمه المكسيكيه منذ
عام
1993 يعلمون بان الزلزال قادم قبل دقيقتين
من بدء الاهتزاز مده قليله في المطلق
لكنها كافيه لانقاذ مئات الالاف من
الاشخاص الذين يهربون للشوارع والسحاب كيف
فعلتها المكسيك رغم انها ليست الاكثر
تقدما تكنولوجيا او علميا كلمه السر موقع
العاصمه في وسط البلاد اما الزلازل التي
تضربها عاده ما تاتي من الجنوب فالسكانها
اقل
تحتك الصفيحه القاريه لامريكا الشماليه
بصحيفه بصفيحه كوكوكس لذلك قام علماء
الزلازل بتركيب اجهزه استشعار في جنوب
البلاد ترشد الهزات الاولى وترسل تحذيرا
الى العاصمه والمدن المجاوره يبدو الحل
بسيطا وفعالا فلماذا لا تطبقه دول اخرى
طورت دول مثل اليابان اجهزه انذار تسبق
الزلزال باقل من دقيقه اما دقيقتان
فالمكسيك وحدها قادره لاسباب جغرافيه كما
اشرنا بتطبيق ذلك على اسطنبول فالمدينه
التي يقتلها 16 مليون نسمه افتتح فيها عام
2021 اول نظام لرصد الزلازل وتسونامي في
مرسى مطل على ساحل مرمره امر سيسمح
بمراقبه الزلازل حوادث الارصاد الجويه
والتغيرات في مستويات السطح البحر لكن
المده ليس دقيقتين وانما تلفون ثانيه
[موسيقى]
الاقامه في بلد ارتبط تاريخه بالزلازل قد
يمثل خطرا نسبيا للبعض لكن الخطر يزداد
على الفقراء المدن الاقل داخل للفرد تتضرر
اكثر من المدن الاعلى في الدخل اليمان
مثلا تضررت اكثر من غازي عنتاب الاقوى
اقتصاديا رغم ان الاخيره اقرب لموقع
الزلزال من الاولى لكن هناك امر لافت في
المباني المدمره الاكثر تضررا لم تكن
الارخص بالضروره ففي قهرمان مرعش كانت
اكثر البنايات تضررا ضمن الفئه السعريه
المتوسطه نحو 6000 ليره للمتر الواحد هذا
الامر ياتي رغم ان المباني الاغلى سعرا
جودتها اعلى لكن هذا يجعل ايضا ارتفاع
المبنى اعلى الامر قد يتحول لنقمه ان لم
تكن البنايه ملتزمه بالكود الزلزالي تماما
كما كلما ارتفع عدد طوابق المبنى وقوه
ووزن المواد المستخدمه في ب سترتفع اعداد
الضحايا ومستوى الصعوبه الانقاذ هذا في
تركيا هل الامر مشابه في بقيه العالم اكثر
من دراسه وجدت ان البلدان ذات الدخل
المتوسط تتكبد المزيد من الخسائر البشريه
في الزلازل مقارنه بالدول ذات الدخل
المنخفض مثل سوريا او ذات الدخل العالي
مثل اليابان الاخيره يمكنها بناء جميع
المباني التزاما بالكود الزلزاليل رغم
انها مكلفه عن العاديه باكثر من 15% اما
الدول ذات الدخل المنخفض فبنائها غالبا ما
يكون افقيا طوابق اقل ومواد خفيفه سيجعلها
بذلك اكثر عرضه للانهيار نعم ولكنها ايضا
تزيد فرص النجاح مقارنه بسقوط حديد فولاذي
فوق السكان اما الدول ذات متوسط الدخل مثل
تركيا فتتجه للتوسع العمرانيه العمودي في
ظل زياده
السكان والاستثمارات وهذا يعني طوابق اكثر
ومواد قويه قوه قد تكون قاتله في حال عدم
الالتزام بالاكواد وهو امر يصعب ضمنه
لاحظنا هذا الامر في بنايه سوريا مقابل
مباني تركيا رغم ان الاخير امتلكت اليات
انقاذ اكثر تطورا الاسكندرون تضررت اكثر
من حلب رغم ان الاخيره اقرب لمركز الزلزال
من الاولى
ليست عصابه تهريب بشر او تجار مخدرات تحدي
مفاجئ جديد امام السلطات الحدود الامريكيه
مع المكسيك البيض من الان واحد الساعه
المقبلات انا حنين الشولي وهذه الساعه 60
[موسيقى]